clearly they're going to be segments of
the economy are going to be affected by
brexit financial services sector is
likely to be one we'll see how that
plays out for us though it's business as
usual we're expanding actually we're
probably an interesting exporter of
services who have just invested quite
heavily in the US market were building a
global business yeah from the capability
that we've got expertise in London the
London economy still doing pretty well
it's the most biggest market for our
services and actually it's quite the
other thing that I think regulation you
know are there any regulations that
actually the European Union in place
that we might be free off now that could
make life easier for business like yours
I don't think in particular for us I
mean the main thing around regulation
for us is our recruitment management of
our driver base and actually there's
quite a lot of new regulation at the
moment very supportive of raising
standards in London so SD cards
introduced new English language test
drivers and we're supportive of that
so actually using regulation working
with the regulator to continue to
improve quality in our industry is one
of our main objectives and there's a lot
of there's a lot of code talk about
self-employment kind of being unemployed
the gig economy anybody's there was a
case involving another company just last
week where a self-employed first managed
you know to challenge the rights that he
was given do you think that that might
be a threat for your business model but
it's really interesting for us so we do
have some fully employed mainly on our
executive show for the dress and 2,000
executive chauffeurs around 250 of those
are employed actually most of our
drivers
value flexibility in what they do it's a
must and marish they're self-employed
now to attract retain of the quality of
service we need they need to be
well-trained they need to be well paid
to written to retain them so that sort
of you know extreme gig economy angle
doesn't really apply to us because
servus we're trying to deliver but
nonetheless might it be the case that
you might have to give them more rights
when it in the future for self-employed
workers and we'll see how the
legislation develops obviously over time
I think for us lots of things that we do
now are not inconsistent with where the
future do we have a set up here in the
UK here in London that will actually
enable it well I think not really at the
moment and I think it's one something
that we need central government to
intervene on so I'm currently TfL review
and trials setting up 300 charging
points in London it's good that the
Doudna trial we think we need about
5,000 of those so we need government
funding for that now I am going to do a
little test here and try and work out
whether I can get a car quicker with you
guys all with uber and then I want you
just to your reactions that's okay I'm
on the Adly app and what's that fight so
five minutes five five minutes not bad
at all but for the best service in
London okay all right let's just sing up
let's see what would be with with uber
okay I'm going to try and work this out
do they say two minutes two minutes yes
very well
and if three minutes is you know that
important to you then you know you
should definitely do that by the time
you've walked outside found your car and
got it anything I seriously don't you
can do that in two minutes
in any event so I think we've got a
pretty good on-demand service there also
60 percent of our work is booked in
advance so if you want to go to the
airport the 5:30 tomorrow morning point
important interview in Frankfurt you're
going to use Addison